Doodle-Doodle-oo, Wadabeepbip-Doo-
oh...Shit.
Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and, welcome to- OH, SHIT!
OA- I don't...AHH! HOW DO I-
I DON'T KNOW!! OH, GOD!
OH, THEY SPED UP IN THE BLOOD FRIEND-
OH, FUCKING SHIT, I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT I'M DOING!
OH, I GOT ONE GUY LEFT.
OOOOAAH, GOD!
Ok...Well, I guess it's much easier, when I just got one guy going...
Ok, so welcome to this game! Oh, LOOK AT HIS LITTLE BUTT GO!
RUN, LITTLE GUY, RUN!
With your stump arms, and your stump legs- WHAO
I guess I earned a friend.
HEH, HYAH, HYEH, HIYAYA!
Oh, shit, ru-JU-A FUUUCKIN'
WHAT WAS I GUNNA DOOOOO?!
WHAT DID I DOOO?!?!
Oh, fuck, alright, HERE WE GO AGAIN, I GUESS!
So, I don't know a lot about this game, but its a quick game that I found on Itch.io and...
It features some adorable artwork, and AAAA
STAY ALIVE! STAY FIT, AND STAY ALIVE!!
OH, GOD. RUN!!! Oh, no, that guy in the back needs to PICK IT UP!
HEP-UP- Oh, only some of them can jump!
EEEEHHHHHH
UUUUUHHHHHH. WUUUUUH. HO-GOD.
I CAN'T SEE, THERE'S SO MUCH BLOOD
OH, GOD, THAT GUY CAN JUMP.
Ok! This is safe! Just stay on each other's heads! You'll be totally fine!
YOU GUYS GOT THIS. YOU GUYS GOT THIS!
oh, you guys don't got this, do you?
you're about to fall off...
HARD TO JUMP, WHEN YOU'RE ON MY HEAD, BRUHH.
Actually, could you get off my h- There we go.
Ok, so each of them have individual characteristics, and I'm certain it's randomly generated.
But, only this guy can jump!
So, I gotta keep track of him!
HUUUH, Make it over? Ok, you made it over. HUH, Make it over!
Ok! *disgruntled noise*
HOEYYY-Ok... *Guy explodes* AEEH! OWWW! :(
*Man scream* WHOAAAAAEYYYY
Ok, alright, EH. eh-eh-eh, OHH, THERE'S SO MUCH BLOOD.
OH, GOD, THERE'S BODY PARTS!
Ok, so, I don't know a lot about this game, and I don't know a lot about what it means...
if its some dystopian society, where you have to do it on this game-show, or die horribly...
Maybe this is the Soylent Green factory...
Oh, geez, I feel so bad for these little guys...
They're so cute and adorable! And this is so horrible and nonstop...
But, I think I'm gonna go for a record here, apparently...
So, this game is completely randomly generated, I suspect, and-
OH, THAT GUY'S GOT MAD HOPS.
whoewhoewhoewhoe
So, it doesn't do...Oh, fu- NOOOOOOOOO!
FUCKING, DUUUUDE
YOU GOT EVERYONE KILLED!!
WHY DID THE GUY THAT COULD JUMP THE BEST BE IN THE BACK, HE COULDN'T HURDLE OVER IT...
*sigh*
man...
These chubby little dudes need to go for it!
They're like little Sackboys! They're like fat little Sackboys!
Oh, man..
OH, HO, GOD, THAT GUY IN THE BACK! HE LOOKS SO COOL, RIGHT BEFORE HE'S ABOUT TO DIE...
And, I gotta admit, this game has some good artstyle to it!
I can...Unify it, at least.
OH, NO.
OH, GOD, NO...
Well, at least there was no blood...That's what I can appreciate. well, that guys dead
I guess if they get crushed under there, there's no place FOR the blood.
I don't know what kind of facility is built like this, just a long hallway of death!
Oh, well. Not gonna question it.
Just gonna...Just gonna live it.
Ok, so, this guy... this guy in the back, he's my champ-
Well, that guy's dead
OOOOH, GOD
WELL, THERE'S THE BLOOD!
I GUESS SOME OF 'EM HAVE BLOOD, AND SOME OF 'EM DO NOT.
Sh-do not get in my way, you ass
YOOU, GOT IN MY WAY, YOU ASS.
OK, YOU BETTER BE ABLE TO JUMP, BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE ANY PATIENCE, FOR THIS- EH
Ooooohhh, FUCK
You've got the worst hops, dude, you've got the minuscule hops.
That guys got no better hops...
At least he's doin'...Ah, he's got a little bit better hops.
OH. THE OTHER GUY RAN OUT OF HOPS.
So, you can only jump so many times, even with the guys that CAN jump...
Alright, there's a bit of a strategy to this one...
There's a bit of a strategy.
Ok. Alright. I got it.
Fuck. NOOOOO! GOD DAMN IT, YOU GOT BOUNCED BACK
GOD, YOU GUYS BETRAY EACH OTHER!
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO SURVIVE, IF THEY JUST WORKED TOGETHER!!
Alright, one more go! One more go on this!
Alright, LET'S DO THIS! COME ON!!!
DON'T FUCK AROUND WITH ME, THIS IS DEATH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE!
IT COMES HARD AND FAST
AND, YOU DON'T WANNA BE S-whoa, we gotta speedy bunch here!
Holy shit-OH MY GOD, there's one super fast guy! Whoa, that zippity doo badda
Oh my god. Oh my god. OK. Oh my- OK, apparently this is- EEEUH!!
WHAT HAPPENED??
Oh god... I think my speedy guy- no, no, we're- we're still here. We're good. We're good!
We're speedy! We're good! Just a lotta death happened, and a lotta of blood exploded everywhere,
But, this time, I'm gonna go for a record!
We're gonna get very far in this one...I've gotta a feeling...
ehhh-NOOOOOO
GOD DAMN IT, YOU FUCKING ASSHOLES!
Oooohh, those poor bastards...
Those poor bastards, they're all dead.
Oh, well. ANYWAY, this is a short little game, there's not much more to it, there's no story, apparently.
I would like to know a story about this!
Why, the hell are they IN this horrible gameshow?!
WHY? IS THERE A POINT?? CAN YOU WIN?! I don't know...
But, either way, that is..."Run, Chubby Dudes, Run", it's a fun little game!
So, I think my record was like, a minute and forty... something seconds, maybe forty six, I have no idea...
But if you guys wanna waste a little bit of time, and... torture some adorable creatures,
then I'll put a link to the game in the description below, so,
Thank you, everybody, so much for watching! And, thank you, developers, for making this sadistic game...
And, as always, I will see you... in the next video.
BUH-BYE!!